Nos dicen: "Laura comenzó su tarea de matemáticas.
Terminó 23 problemas por sí misma. Terminó 13
problemas más con ayuda de Sal", no estoy seguro
si están hablando de mí o no, pero después nos
dicen que "Quedan 9 problemas de matemáticas por
resolver", y nos preguntan "¿Cuántos problemas
tenía Laura en un principio?" Así que pausa el
video e intenta encontrar la respuesta por tu
cuenta antes de trabajar juntos. Muy bien la
forma en la que lo resolví es la siguiente.
Hay una cantidad de problemas iniciales,
así que pongamos una gran barra por aquí:
esta es la cantidad de problemas que tiene
Laura en un principio, así que vamos a anotarlo,
esta es la cantidad inicial, y después resolvió
varios de estos problemas, aquí dice "terminó
23 problemas por sí misma", así que vamos a
plasmarlo: ella hizo 23 problemas por sí misma;
después nos dicen: terminó 13 problemas más con la
ayuda de alguien con mi nombre -tal vez sea yo-,
entonces ella realizó 13 problemas más con ayuda
de Sal; y por último, nos dicen que la cantidad de
problemas que faltan por resolver son 9; por lo
tanto, la cantidad de problemas que faltan debe
de completar la cantidad total de problemas, es
decir, la extenderemos hasta el final de la barra
de problemas iniciales. Entonces aquí tenemos
9 faltantes, tenemos los 23 que resolvió por sí
misma, los 13 que resolvió con ayuda de un tal Sal
y los 9 que le faltan por resolver. Por lo tanto,
si queremos saber la cantidad de problemas
iniciales, ¿cuántos problemas tenía Laura
en un principio? Tendremos que sumar 23
más 13 más 9. ¿Cómo lo hacemos? Bueno,
vamos paso por paso. Primero pensemos en la
cantidad de problemas que ya terminó y después
le sumaremos a eso la cantidad de problemas
faltantes, con eso obtendremos la cantidad
inicial. La cantidad que ya terminó es esta
cantidad que tenemos aquí, los que ella terminó
por sí misma y los que ella terminó con ayuda de
Sal, esto es 23 + 13. Ahora, 23 es lo mismo que,
si tenemos dos decenas, entonces 20 + 3, mientras
que 13 es lo mismo que 10 + 3 -el 1 está en el
lugar de las decenas-, 10 + 3; y si primero
sumamos las decenas tenemos 20 + 10, + 3 + 3,
esto será lo mismo que 20 + 10 es 30
y 3 + 3 es 6, así que esto será 36. Así
que todo esto que tenemos aquí es la cantidad
de problemas que Laura resolvió por sí misma y
con ayuda de Sal, son 36 problemas. Ahora bien,
para encontrar la cantidad inicial, sumaremos la
cantidad que realizó más la cantidad faltante,
entonces: ¿cuánto es 36 + 9? Bueno, la forma en
la que resuelvo esto es la siguiente: 36 + 9 es
igual a, bueno esto es lo mismo que 30 + 6 + 9,
seguramente sabes que 6 + 9 es 15. Otra forma de
ver esto es que si a 9 le sumas 1 obtienes 10,
y si después sumamos los 5 que nos quedan
del 6 obtenemos 15. Entonces, otra forma de
reescribir esto es 30 + 15, que es lo mismo que
30 + 10 + 5, 30 + 10 es igual a esto de aquí es
40, 40 + 5 = 45. Por lo tanto, Laura empezó con
45 problemas, terminó 23 problemas por sí misma,
después terminó 13 problemas más con ayuda de Sal
y le quedan 9 problemas por resolver. Podemos ver
que si empezamos con 45 y le restamos 23 y después
13, en efecto, obtendremos 9 problemas faltantes.